sur les parkings de certains Ikea ou
Castorama chaque jour il arrive que des
dizaines d'hommes sans papier en quête
de travail attendent dans l'espoir
d'être embauchés au black par des
artisans selon un policier les migrants
se postent là où il y a du travail à
prendre devant les enseignes de
bricolage mais aussi sur les parkings
des magasins IKEA où ils proposent leurs
services pour charger le véhicule et
monter les meubles toute une
organisation où chaque communauté a sa
place selon qu'on vient du Maghreb
d'Albanie ou d'Afrique subsaharienne ils
arrivent à l'aube des 5 ou 6h du matin
et attendent par exemple au pied du
Castorama de la zone industrielle de
pierely dans le valdoise un spot bien
connu des clandestins ces hommes savent
que des dizaines de particuliers et
d'artisans arpentent les rayons et
feront appel à eux en échange de
plusieurs heures de peinture ou de
maçonnerie on leur glissera quelques
billets dans la poche ils se sont tous
formés sur le tas comme Aboubakar un
guinéen de 47 ans qui a appris la
peinture la pose d'enduit et l'isolation
avec un Marocain Abdou lui un Sénégalais
de 32 ans se rend tous les jours à
pierley pour décrocher le maximum de
petits boulot il est là dès l'ouverture
du magasin à 8h ce jour-là il réussit à
trouver un client j'ai rendez-vous
demain à 8h30 garde de Franconville pour
des travaux d'End i et de peinturees il
espère obtenir 70 € pour la journée pour
Rachid chef d'entreprise ces ouvriers ne
coûtent pas cher et sont vaillants car
eux ils en veulent ils cassent les murs
il déblai et en 2 heures il vous font
une tranchée sans brocher il les oppos
même à ceux ceux qui restent au chômage
et au RSA mais quand leur présence se
fait trop envahissante la directrice du
Castorama n'hésite pas à appeler la
police ils reviennent à chaque fois en
attendant sur le trottoir ce qui revient
dans toutes les conversations ce sont
les papiers c'est cesâes qu'ils n'ont
pas ou alors les faux qu'ils se sont
procurés et il discutent même du projet
de loi immigration qui prévoit la
possible rgularisation des S papiers
dans les secteurs en tension bien sûr on
est au courant mais j'ai vu sur BFM que
c'est pas
voté